is 3 comma negative 4 a solution to the
equation 5x plus 2y is equal to 7. so
there's two ways to think about it one
you could just substitute this x and y
value into this equation to see if it
satisfies it and we'll do that way first
and the other way is if you had a graph
of this equation you could see if this
if this point sits on that graph which
would also mean that it is a solution to
this equation so let's do it the first
way so we have 5x plus 2y is equal to 7.
so let's substitute instead of x let us
put in 3
let's put in 3 for x so 5 times 3
plus
plus 2 times y
so y is negative 4
plus 2 times negative 4 needs to be
equal to
needs to be equal to 7. i'll put a
question mark here because we're not
sure yet if it does so 5 times 3
5 times three is fifteen
and then two times negative four two
times negative four is negative eight
so the left hand side it simplifies to
15 minus eight and this needs to be
equal to 7 and of course 15 minus 8 does
equal 7. so this all works out this is a
solution so we've answered the question
but i also want to show you this way we
just did it by substitution if we had
the graph of this equation we could also
do it graphically so let's let's give
ourselves the graph of this equation
i'll do that by setting up a table
there's multiple ways to graph this you
could put it in the slope intercept form
and all of the rest but i'll just set up
a table of x and y values
x and y values and i'll graph it and
then given the graph i want to see if
this actually sits on it and obviously
it will because we've already shown that
this works in fact we could try the
point 3 negative 4 and that actually is
on the graph we could do it on our table
but i won't do that just yet i'm just
going to do this to give ourselves a
graph
so let's say
let's try it when x is equal to 0 we
have 5 times 0 plus 2 times y is equal
to 7. so when x is equal to 0 y is going
to be so you're going to have 0 plus 2y
is equal to 7 y is going to be equal to
3.5
when x is equal to 1
when x is equal to 1 you have 5 plus 2y
is equal to 7. you're going to have 5
plus 2y
is equal to 7. if you subtract 5 from
both sides you get 2y is equal to 2
you get y is equal to 1. so when x is 1
y is 1
and when x is
well let's try
let's try well that's actually enough
for us to graph we could keep doing but
we could keep doing more points we could
even put the point 3 negative 4 there
but let's just try to graph it in this
very rough sense right here
so
let me
draw my
x-axis
and then this right over here is my
y-axis
and let me draw some points here so
let's say that this is y is one
two
three
four this is negative one negative two
negative three negative four i could
keep going down in that direction
this is one
let me do it a little bit
one
two
three four and i could just keep going
on and on in the positive x direction so
let's plot these points of zero three
point five when x is zero y is one two
three
point five
when x is one y is one when x is one y
is one and so if we were to draw this
line i'll do it as a dotted line just so
that i can
make sure i connect to the dots i can do
a better job than that though
so it will look it will look something
something
like that
and so if you if someone gave you this
line you said oh well it's 3 negative 4
on this line and let's assume that we
drew it really let's assume that we drew
it really nicely and this was all to
scale let me try one last attempt at it
let me one last attempt at it
so it's going to look something
it's going to look something like that
and if someone asks is 3 negative 4 on
it you could visually do it but it's
always hard when you're when you
actually don't substitute it because you
don't know maybe you're a little bit off
but if you're here if you look at over
here you say when x is equal to 3 what
is y well you go down here and it looks
like y is equal to negative 4. so this
is a point 3 comma
3 comma negative 4. obviously you won't
you in general you don't want to just
rely off of inspecting a graph maybe
this was like 3
negative 3.9999 and you just couldn't
tell looking at the graph that's why you
always want to just substitute and make
sure that it really does equal that this
equality really does hold true at that
point not just looking at the graph but
it's important to realize that the graph
really is another representation to all
of the solutions of this equation